of ukraine moldova in georgia we have
decided to grant candidate status to
ukraine and moldova and you are ready to
grant candy status to georgia once
priorities will be addressed it's more
historic this is a historic moment which
allows us to
design the contours of the european
union by deciding today to ground the
stun status of candidate to ukraine and
to moldova and also to be prepared to
grant this candidate status to georgia
once the priorities will have been
addressed taking into account for all
the countries the reports and the
opinions which have been prepared and
which will be prepared by the european
commission it's a very strong message
which is being sent out
it's a message of unity of determination
uh
in political terms and we've had an
opportunity to connect with uh president
uh zelensky just a few moments before
this press conference and we'll meet
with the
uh the other presidents
uh yes
and my son do later hopefully
now it was an opportunity to
decide on the
extension and amplification of support
to ukraine financially militarily we
also had an opportunity in our uh
conclusions to say
uh that we will
address the consequences
of this russian aggression on ukraine
for example food security and uh
the whole issue of energy and then this
morning we had an opportunity to meet
the leaders of the western balkans that
was an opportunity for a dense fruitful
intense
exchange and it was also an opportunity
to reaffirm our desire to breathe new
life into this commitment process
that we have with the
western balkans now we want to encourage
reform in the area of rule of law
independence of justice
fighting corruption but it's also
important to
be engaged with them to resolve a number
of disputes which have constituted or
still constitute breaks that hold us
back so we really want to move forward
so we're staying uh
we're staying committed
uh we've got this
northern macedonia and we're really
trying to find a solution the strongest
of the parliament has to take some
decisions over the next few hours and we
do hope we're going to be able to free
up the negotiation process with north
macedonia and also albania which is
directly concerned by this uh debate we
also had an opportunity with
in respect to bosnia-herzegovina there
was a real desire around the table to
breathe new life into the process with
bosnia herzegovina there was a
suggestion made that fairly quickly the
commission could actually come up with a
report on the various uh
conditions so that the european council
could come back to the issue of
bosnia-herzegovina we said that we're
prepared
to decide on the uh status of candidate
taking into account the conclusions of
the report to be prepared by the
commission furthermore we
support uh what uh
the conclusions from the the uh uh high
representative on the dialogue between
belgrade and pristina
we really do want to uh you know
deliver some political impetus so that's
basically what we discussed
today so far i don't want to speak at
such great length we will be continuing
uh
later on we're going to discuss the
whole issue of a european political
community
the some preparatory work of has been
done the western balkan legals were able
to react tentatively to this and they
were rather favorable to it which was an
interesting idea
and i'd like to thank in particular the
french presidency
because this is the last european
council during the french presidency at
least in principle i'd like to thank you
for the excellent cooperation for your
engagement your commitment to the
european project
to uh full uh mobilization we're going
to be continuing to this evening and
tomorrow we'll be able to come back
tomorrow to some of the achievements of
the french presidency but i really
wanted here and now this evening to get
uh over this message of gratitude to the
full team
of the french presidency and in
particular i'd like to thank the
president of the republic so that's it
from me thank you
thank you so much i can be very brief
because this is a very defining moment
and a very good day for europe today
i warmly congratulate president
zielenski
president sandu president zura bishvili
all three countries are part of our
european family we've never let any
doubt about that and today's historic
decision by leaders confirms that
it grants all three the perspective of
eu accession
and it lays down the path ahead i think
this is a moment of great satisfaction
and i'm very pleased with the leaders
endorsement of our opinions
there can be no better sign of hope for
the citizens of ukraine moldova and
georgia
in these troubled times
of course the countries all have to do
homework before moving to the next stage
of the accession process
but i am convinced that they will all
move as swiftly as possible and work as
hard as possible to implement the
necessary reforms
not just because they are required to
move ahead in the european accession
path
but first and foremost because these
reforms are good for the countries good
for the democracy
because it strengthens the
competitiveness of all three countries
and ultimately they are good for the
citizens
let me stress that i'm deeply convinced
that our decision that we have taken
today strengthened us all
it strengthens ukraine moldova and
georgia in the face of russian
aggression
and it strengthens the european union
because it shows once again to the world
that the european union is united
and strong
in the face of external threats thank
you so much thank you
mr president uh you have a floor thank
you very much well everything's been
said
i just wanted to stress
just how important this historic moment
is in the context we're living through
right now a war
decided on by russia
against ukraine and its people on
ukraine's soil
a week ago in kiev went together with
olive schultz and mario draghi from
germany in italy
and klasianis from romania
we
took this commitment
to
get an agreement to give ukraine
candidates status to exceed the european
union which is the starter of a roadmap
we knew it all depended on the process
and over the last week
we have made some giant strides forward
thanks to work done by the european
commission first of all
they've proposed a method on
the basis
of work done together with ukraine
and then together with president
michelle
consensus has
been forged unanimity indeed between the
members of the council and
we saw this with president zielinski a
very strong message a coherent message
right from day one of the conflict
europe's been reacting quickly this is
historic we've been united
first with sanctions two days afterwards
then the macroeconomic and military
support financial support we brought to
ukraine and now by this political
gesture
so i think this strong
united europe
has been up to the task
we're offering now a european
perspective to ukraine moldova and
georgia that's a strong signal
towards russia in the current
geopolitical context
with uh
our choice
to give ukraine although the state has
been candidates to join the eu
also we decided the candidates
will be granted to georgia once they
have met for priorities which have been
identified by the commission
we owe this to the ukrainian people
they're fighting to defend our values
their sovereignty territorial integrity
and also moldova given its political uh
situation with destabilization it
suffers from we also uh need to
respond
with the same generosity that they've
shown in this context that we're
reacting to
it will be a long way it will be
demanding the commission will produce a
report on uh the conditions
that's where the respective conditions
at london very far last week and
certainly we will be ready to help out
from france there any reforms they need
in this process to build unity president
michelle moreover
in a detailed way has
described our discussions about the
western balkans this morning on the
start of this afternoon
let me say too that we will do our
utmost
to
make sure that the vote can be moved in
the bulgarian parliament and i think
that's our responsibility as europa to
meet this opportunity too
so that north macedonia can take the
last step but they've done so much
already they've taken so many risks
in the coming days and weeks then
we need to be able to make that
breakthrough too and also for
albania and so that way
an important step decides step forward
in this process it all shows that uh our
neighborhood where we're talking about
ukraine moldova georgia western balkans
is more essential
than ever
because war is back on european soil
we're destabilized by what's going on in
our neighborhood and so it's in that
context
that
we're going to discuss this evening
forms of cooperation multiple forms of
cooperation
beyond enlargement and the project of
european political cooperation which as
president michelle
uh has uh recalled was defended bearish
by serbia albania and several colleagues
uh that's it from me for now thanks very
much to the
uh president and president of the
commission for fantastic work which is
now today's historic decision today
erisa you're first please there's a mike
yeah
um
good evening i have a question for all
three of you
now the european union has broken a lot
of taboos
during the french presidency and you
have all contributed to that but how do
you explain the
impotence of
the european union
when it comes to albania and
northern macedonia when all you have is
just one
country in the member state that has
this particular uh problem and uh you
know the doors are still not quite over
open are they uh
a lot of work has been done
what's true is that northern macedonia
has done some historic work with the
courage of various leaders once they
have took a lot of risks to change the
name of the country the constitution
now it happened a bit late in the day
that one member state asked for
changes
now we can't pretend that didn't exist
now whether that's
fair towards not mustang era
um
i would say uh not and so we put a lot
of pressure on bulgaria uh in recent
months and this is the the result of a
political crisis that's happened
recently in bulgaria we can't pretend
that isn't happening i'd like to pay
tribute to the prem to the
prime minister his courage he's done
everything he possibly could
so i think we're very close to an
agreement we've made a proposal
uh working very closely together and
that
allows us to accommodate the uh
bulgarian
requests which is uh compatible with
what north macedonia can do but
obviously it's about visibility now and
building trust over the next few hours
what has been agreed there'll be a vote
taking place in the bulgarian parliament
and i'm relying on all uh people across
the political spectrum in bulgaria to
support this now we'll look to the
president of the republic we'll have to
make a commitment here
the parties in the current
majority those who are in the uh
coalition and those those who just left
it those in the uh
opposition should vote on this is their
european duty
uh and over the next few hours there'll
be a discussion with the north
macedonians to finalize the agreement
now if everything moves forward as such
then hopefully
next week we'll be able to have the
co-repair meetings the process and
move forward and get enough macedonia
and albania moving forward but you're
quite right there's been a lot of
waiting uh done
despite all the efforts
question for the president of the french
republic from me
three years ago
you uh talked a long time after a summit
about enlargement
and you said you had a feeling that
evening that the only response
europe
has is to get people in other countries
to become members
and they said
i won't be uh
president of that time
have you done
the same thing now as the situation for
ukraine quite different
well it comes back to what i was saying
a few weeks ago
in the european parliament now first of
all those we have countries which are
committed in this procedure a train's
left a station
and they've got their their
ticket uh ready to travel
there's western balkans serbia
montenegro you can't tell them now
uh
i you can't tell albania and north
macedonia but it's all over because
they've made lots of has to open
chapters some of them
uh others have had uh
many uh years their status uh as
candidates but not being able to open
chapters to negotiate yet it's a
question of credibility and also a
geopolitical issue to stabilize the
balkans
now regardless of all durva and ukraine
to be quite clear
it is a political uh message and i
assume that in a given jupiter context
i'll be quite frank about this uh
no we won't be there straight away it'll
take time there's a road map to get
there it could take years even longer in
the european parliament
why
because the logic
remains the same and i'll be
forceful about this when we talk about
our neighbor and if we want to stabilize
our neighborhood we got to let them
into our home an idea is that we need to
have a neighborhood
which
is part of us
um because otherwise that you will set
limits and about but the only particular
existence you have never create tensions
there is a
tension between the geopolitical
uh approach of doing that and also
the deepening of what we have already
and uh
serbia is another example serbia over
the last seven years has been committed
to this process but it's so demanding
because we meant have made a lot of
progress
so the geopolitical response today in
the context of war is to continue to
offer this perspective
now in terms of how long it's going to
take
is it is it the same well i say as i
said for you is go no because it's going
to take time and we are seeing a fatigue
an enlargement fatigue phenomenon
amongst uh countries that have shown
but countries have been in this uh
process for years and years and years
it's too long it's terrible it's
difficult to carry out reforms that you
demanded it's a long road to travel
and that is why too i proposed in the
meantime european political
community which rings the right response
okay we've got the eu you can get there
we've got processes to become a member
for enlargement and i'm very very
trained for started but it will take a
lot of time let's be lucid that maybe
won't work out for some of these
countries but in the meantime we need to
think much more quickly how we can
stabilize our neighborhood
and let's be honest
maybe we won't always be living together
in the same house but we're living on
the same street
so we geographically we're together we
share to certain extent the same values
but we have some different standards on
some things
we have different uh economic levels
which don't allow us to be instantly a
single market but we have to strengthen
our links between each other as equals
and i i see a need for new european
construction we're going to talk about
this evening and that's what it's all
about
you know along the russian
turkish
border
right down
to our westernmost point
the uk
and anybody in between is not actually
an eu member we need to build something
together we need to cooperate together
on defense geopolitics energy
infrastructure
movement of people very specific
projects which will allow us to change
the lives of people
and you know twice a year we get a real
geopolitical discussion of all these
countries exchanging a common agenda and
build a broader geopolitical right we
need that
but that's not necessarily the eu per se
because we have such a degree of
integration strategic intimacy economic
and social intimacy such strong
integration we cannot sacrifice that in
the name of this broader geopolitical
need we need to
work together for two so no my landlord
is the same as three years ago but right
now
we're for good reasons
nato
said no to ukraine membership
we would have left a a vacuum created a
political era if we had said no now to
ukraine and moldova because we don't yet
have this political community
and we can't leave a strategic jupiter
vacuum there that is the whole purpose
of offering this european perspective
recognizing the canada's status of these
countries question from georgia please
yes take the mic
uh georgian taylor
yeah georgian theory company rustavi two
first of all congratulations to our
ukrainian and moldovan friends uh
decisions already made now the main
message from you to georgia to georgian
people and your advice how can quickly
we meet these criterias to um
have this candidate status to
it finally to be a candidate countries
also as our friends thank you the first
the first the first message to the the
the georgian people into the german
authorities this is the european
perspective it's a very clear and very
strong message trying to address to them
they know that i had the occasion to
work a lot with the georgian authorities
the recent months because i'm totally
convinced that this is extremely
important for the country for the people
of the country to implement to implement
the fundamental reforms the fight
against corruption the independence of
justice and we are very very close with
all the the georgian institutions you
know to for them to make progress and
based on the report of the commission
and based on the work
of the commission i am confident if
there is a political will
in the political landscape within
georgia that it could be possible for
them to make huge progress because i
know that they know exactly what's
needed in order to take steps in the
right direction and and today we sent a
very strong message at the geopolitical
level but not only at the geopolitical
level we know there is a
choice made by the georgian people and
the georgian authorities this is the
choice for the free world it's a choice
for the fundamental values for the
fundamental principle for the democratic
principles and we really want to work
closely with them you know to support
their efforts and to work in the right
direction
i think
i think my message to the georgian
people is indeed
the enormous desire you have and the
longing to the european union
is the strongest push
on the path forward to the european
union and
georgia has now gotten the perspective
this is a big step very substantial the
perspective
towards the accession
to become a member of the european union
this is
for the first time
that they reach that stage you have a
strong
there has been a lot of political
progress
now what is needed is to deliver on a
few reforms that are important and to
show political unity
to engage the civil society and to move
forward on these reforms and then the
next steps are within reach
as we are reconvening in a couple of
minutes
i would fully uh support what the
president uh madam president uh has said
it's historic day let's recognize uh
that for georgia prospective membership
and the commission has said very clearly
what the uh
conditions are for
gaining that state as a candidate and
that was mentioned by the president i
think we've seen
uh just uh
how clear
the georgian president's message was and
uh georgian people went out into the
streets and called for more europe so
there's this
ground swell of of support
for europe and that will be the basis
for these reforms to be carried out
so we'll have to cut it short here thank
you very much
we'll see each other very soon
thanks
[Music]
you